Before we get going today, I have an exciting update for you. Hidden Brain is now on YouTube, not the audio podcast, which will continue to be available on Apple, Spotify, and your favorite audio podcast player, but as a brand new standalone video channel. Please check us out. Our first videos include an exploration of the science of bravery, the secret behind artistic masterpieces, and a set of ideas to deal with high-pressure situations. Our handle on YouTube is at Hidden Brain, or just click the link in the show notes for today's episode. Again, that's YouTube.com slash at Hidden Brain. Okay, here's today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. To be prepared for war is one of the most effectual means of preserving peace.
Those are the words of the first U.S. President George Washington in his inaugural State of the Union address. George Washington knew a thing or two about war. Over four decades of military service, he took part in a number of bloody battles. Among them was the Battle of Trenton, in which American colonists battled German soldiers paid to fight for the British. The battle was depicted in the 2000 film The Crossing. In scene after scene, the Americans thrust their bayonets into the Germans. They kill others with cannon and musk. fire. Their enemies repeatedly try to regroup, but are forced to flee.
Finally, the Germans, realizing they cannot win, kneel in surrender. These scenes, like many depictions of war, can be hard to watch. But they also force us to face uncomfortable questions. Doesn't Washington's war, and countless others like it, prove that the realists are right, that violence is the most effective means to change, that power does flow from the barrel of a gun. This week on Hidden Brain, the surprising truth about what actually produces radical change and the profound implications for individuals and nations. Many of us watch movies depicting war or TV shows where detectives saved the day by bursting
in on the bad guys, guns blazing. These sorts of stories are based on an assumption. Using force might be unpleasant. It might even be immoral, but it's highly effective, the surest way to get what you want. At Harvard University, political scientist Erica Chenoweth studies whether this common assumption is true when it comes to mass movements for change. Erica Chenoweth, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. Erica, I want to look at your own journey into this area of research.
When you were a kid, your mom bought you a book called Zlatta's Diary. You were enthralled by this book. What was it about? Basically, this is the story written by Zelata Filippa witch about what it was like living as a child under siege during the siege of Sarajevo. As a 13-year-old kid, I couldn't help but be moved by the experiences of being a kid that were not going to be available to her, her friends, and others because of the war. I mean, in many ways, it's like the fascination that many people have had over the years with, you know, the diary of Anne Frank. It gives you a window into what it's like to go through the experience of war. Later on, I understand you became really interested in the history of World War I. You'd go to the public library with your family, and you loved a book about World War I Medal of Honor winners. What was the appeal of the book? Well, I think I was always really fascinated with World War I. I can't actually remember that. origins of the fascination, to be honest. But from the time I can remember, I was looking at military history books and one that really caught my eye was the one about Medal of Honor winners,
in part because it described these situations of heroism and courage, but also these situations of just horrific wartime conditions, trench warfare and the types of experiences that people had just serving in the war on and off the battlefield. As an undergrad, I understand you took a military science class. So it sounds like you were developing a real interest here in military history. Yes, I was interested in potentially serving in the Army after graduating from college. And they had an ROTC program, which I didn't eventually enroll in, but I did take the military science course to find out whether it was a path for me.
The September 11th terrorist attacks took place during Erica's senior year in college. They prompted Erica to go to graduate school to better understand the nature of terrorism. And there was a really influential article and later book published by a scholar named Robert Pape, who's at the University of Chicago. And he basically argued that suicide terrorism was on the increase because it was a remarkably effective technique. And, you know, there was a debate about that. this. And another really important article and set of arguments was emerging from a fellow named Max
Abrams. And he was arguing that actually looking beyond just suicide terrorism, if you look at terrorist events and you look at sort of campaigns of terrorism or terrorist groups, and you look at how many of those groups have actually achieved what they said they wanted, it's a remarkably low number. And so he was saying that terrorism was not effective. And then there was this other political scientists saying that suicide terrorism in particular is very effective. So there was sort of a vibrant debate happening in the field. And my research was really on the question of why it is that people use terrorism in democracies, specifically where there are so many other methods of political expression that are available. So that's sort of where I was in the mid-2000s as well.
Would it be fair to say that your broad belief at this point was that power indeed does flow from the barrel of a gun, from your interest in military history and your knowledge of wars past and present? Yeah, I think that's right. And I think I would qualify it somewhat just by saying that it flows from the barrel of many guns. So, you know, and I think there are a lot of people that would make a similar assumption, that when violence failed, it was more a question of capacity, that rebel groups or terrorist groups were using violence but didn't have really the capacity to back up their political might. I just want to stop for a second to note that the intuition that you had is I feel like an intuition that many people have in the culture, right? When we think about, you know,
how, what succeeds in terms of bringing about change, whether that's change on an individual level or a group level or a political level, we see lots of examples. We see movies and books, which are all about the use of violence and war that basically achieve people's ends. And in some ways, it feels like that intuition sort of flows through our lives in a way that's often not questioned. I think that's true. I mean, I think from a very early time in life, at least in the United States, many children are encountering, you know, war stories. And whether that's about the founding of the country, whether it's about the civil war, the Vietnam War, we encounter these fairly early on. And they're sort of memorialized and mythologized in ways. And
to me, I guess I grew up with a sense that war was awful but necessary sometimes or inevitable because of the nature of humanity. And yeah, I think you're right that as a political culture, there's little questioning of the utility of violence. So in June 2006, you were, I believe, working on your dissertation and you were attending an academic workshop, but some of what you heard at this workshop made you skeptical. What was the workshop? What was the workshop? and what were people saying? It was a workshop that was put on by the International Center on Nonviolent Conflict, which is an educational foundation based in D.C.
The thing that was really surprising about it was that the content was all totally new to me. And, you know, the basic claim, I would say, running through all of the content was that nonviolent resistance, when unarmed civilians use protests, boycotts, strikes, stayaways, other forms of non-cooperation, that they can actually engage in collective action in a way that's as effective or even more effective than when they use armed insurgency. And the first thing that occurred to me is that when people would refer to particular cases, like the people power movement in the Philippines, or the solidarity movement in Poland, or the anti-Pinochet movement in Chile, you know, my immediate response,
was those are very interesting cases. I hadn't really thought about them in terms of, you know, nonviolent collective action winning compared to armed insurrection. But for any example that someone brought up, I could think of a counter example of where an armed revolution had succeeded. Erica immediately also thought about nonviolent protest movements that had failed, like the peaceful pro-democracy protests at Tiananmen Square in China in 1989. As the world watches and listens in horror, the peaceful pro-democracy demonstration in China comes to a violent and bloody end, crushed by waves of Chinese military forces, hundreds of unarmed civilians, hungry for freedom, mowed down in Beijing by gun-firing soldiers.
And Tiananmen Square was not the only example of a failed, non-violent uprising that occurred to Erica. Well, you know, there's certainly plenty of examples more recently, the one that springs to mind immediately as the Syrian revolution. But, you know, that's another example of where, you know, you have a sustained mobilization that is up against a regime that effectively decided that it could roll the dice and use extreme brutality and suppress the movement effectively. And of course, you know, even a cursory glance at history suggests numerous examples where violent interaction succeeded. I mean, and starting with, you know, the American Revolution or the French Revolution. Yes, absolutely. I mean, start with the Haitian Revolution and the American Revolution, the French
And Tiananmen Square was not the only example of a failed, non-violent uprising that occurred to Erica. Well, you know, there's certainly plenty of examples more recently, the one that springs to mind immediately as the Syrian revolution. But, you know, that's another example of where, you know, you have a sustained mobilization that is up against a regime that effectively decided that it could roll the dice and use extreme brutality and suppress the movement effectively. And of course, you know, even a cursory glance at history suggests numerous examples where violent interaction succeeded. I mean, and starting with, you://g, the American Revolution or the French Revolution. Yes, absolutely. I mean, start with the Haitian Revolution and the American Revolution, the French
revolution, the Russian Revolution, the Algerian Revolution, the Chinese Revolution. So we have, we have many different examples that leap immediately to mind. You know, most people, I think, wouldn't necessarily imagine that there's really anything about nonviolent resistance that could make it even compete with that. As Erica marshalled example after example of violent revolutions that were effective on non-violent movements that had failed, another political scientist at the conference, Maria Stephan, threw down a challenge. Examples showing violent and non-violent movements succeeding or failing were just that.
revolution, the Russian Revolution, the Algerian Revolution, the Chinese Revolution. So we have, we have many different examples that leap immediately to mind. You://g, most people, I think, wouldn't necessarily imagine that there's really anything about nonviolent resistance that could make it even compete with that. As Erica marshalled example after example of violent revolutions that were effective on non-violent movements that had failed, another political scientist at the conference, Maria Stephan, threw down a challenge. Examples showing violent and non-violent movements succeeding or failing were just that.
Examples. They were anecdotes. They weren't data. Now, it's never possible to rerun historical events. You couldn't ask the question, would the French revolution have succeeded if it had been nonviolent? You couldn't rewind the clock of history, run the revolution differently, and see if the outcome might have turned out another way. But Maria asked Erica if there was still a way to scientifically test which approach was more effective. Basically, my answer to Maria was how I would do it is I would collect data for a very long time period. I would use every country in the world as the universe of potential cases. And then I would look for comparable cases featuring primarily nonviolent resistance and violent resistance.
And by comparable cases, I mean cases that were seeking similar goals. And I would apply a hard standard to that and look only at cases that were seeking radical revolutionary goals, not looking at, say, civil rights campaigns or different types of reform. campaigns, but look at campaigns that we're trying to overthrow the incumbent national government or campaigns that were trying to push for independence, either by expelling a foreign military occupation or colonial power or through secession, because those are the types of goals that most people associate in their minds with armed revolution. And then let's apply a very strict definition of success, which is that the campaign had to have achieved its outcome within a
year of the peak of its mobilization, and it had to have had a decisive impact on the outcome and achieved what it said it wanted. So in the case of independence campaigns, they can't just achieve autonomy. It has to be de jure and de facto independence. And the reason to set it up that way is because if you were a skeptic like me, you would want to compare the hard cases and you'd want to be able to come up with some kind of measure of the relative effectiveness given those very strict criteria. Erica was proposing an incredibly high bar to test the effectiveness of nonviolent movements. Maria Stefan's response? Let's do it.
Let's find all the cases of insurrections and revolutions over more than a century where groups of people sought to overthrow a regime. Let's classify them as violent or non-violent, based on how the campaigns were predominantly carried out, and see which ones succeeded. By comparing lots and lots of cases, the research, could finally say something objective about the relative effectiveness of the two strategies. Erica said okay, but was quite sure what they would find. All the childhood books, all the military history Erica had absorbed, pointed in the same direction. Non-violent movements might be
high-minded, but violent movements would be more effective. When we come back, what the political scientists found. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. Erica Chenoweth grew up fascinated by stories of war and military heroism. Like many people, Erica recoiled at the horrors of war, but came to believe that violence was an effective way to accomplish one's goals. Popular culture endorsed this idea. Movies, books, and TV regularly tell us that if you really want to get your way on something,
force is probably the most effective strategy. In 2006, Erica met another political scientist, Maria Stephan, who threw down a challenge. If violence was really more effective than nonviolence in enacting change, the historical data should prove it. If you compare the history of violent insurrections with nonviolent campaigns for change, you should find that the people who used guns were far more successful than the people who didn't use weapons. Erica and Maria began to analyze hundreds of cases of conflict and rebellion starting in the year 1900. Erica, I want to start by looking at some of the cases you and Maria examined, and let's start with this one. In October 2000, hundreds of thousands of protesters gathered in the city of Belgrade.
There were massive demonstrations calling for government reform. One evening in October, a large crowd gathered in front of the city's parliament building. They chanted, he's finished. He's finished. Who were they talking about? Well, they were talking about Slobodan Milosevic. One of his nicknames is the butcher of the Balkans, who had stolen an election that had taken place in the previous weeks. And the movement that organized in advance of the election had expected Milosevic to lie about the results of the election
and had set up these parallel vote tabulation and very well. organized kind of verification processes to demonstrate the fraud. So the Serbian organization was called Otpur, and Otpour really became famous for using humor and theatrics in their anti-Milosevic protests. One such campaign was called a dinar for change. Activists painted Milosevic's face on a barrel and placed it in front of the Belgrade National Theater. People who passed by could pay a small amount of money to then hit the painting with a bat. It was like a game you play at a county fair. I want to play you a clip of one of the leaders, Sergei Popovich, explaining the strategy in a TED Talk.
We put the big petrol barrel with a portrait picture of Mr. President on it. In the middle of the mainstream, there was a hole on the top. So you could literally come, put the coin in, get the baseball bat, and hit his face. Sounds loud. We were sitting in a nearby cafe having coffee and there was a clue of people waiting to do this lovely thing well that's just the beginning of the show the real show starts when the police appears what they will do arrest the shoppers with kids doesn't make sense of course you could bet they've done the most stupid thing they arrested the barrel and now the picture of the smashed face on the barrel with the policeman drugging them to the
police car that was the best day for the photographers from newspapers that they ever will have What was the effect of this campaign, Erica? There's no doubt that Oatpour had a really important impact on opening people's minds to imagining a new future. One of the long-term legacies of that campaign was the different types of tactical innovations that were experimented with there. In particular, the type of method that Serja was just describing is called a dilemma action. And a dilemma action is something that. Oatpore really perfected. The dilemma is, what do you do? So do you just leave it and ignore it?
Then you have all of these people smashing Milosevic's face. Or do you arrest somebody, anybody who's there, create a scene. It would look illegitimate. Or do you put the barrel in the police car and then, you know, it's sort of this humiliating and absurd political theater. But it's a technique that is now used in a much more widespread way, I would think. because the logic of it is clearer to people. And the other thing, of course, is the humor. And humor is really important as a way to really poke at the invincibility kind of myth or narrative that exists among many different autocrats or autocratic movements. And so if there's one thing that we know that autocrats don't like, it's people laughing at them.
One of my favorite vignettes comes from Morocco, where there is an independence movement in western Sahara, and it's illegal to fly the colors of the flag of the independence movement. And there was a group of protesters who wanted to mobilize a flag, an illegal flag-flying protest. And they announced in advance that this would be taking place so that the authorities would show up. But instead of themselves showing up to fly the flag, they basically rounded up a bunch of stray cats and tied the flags onto their tails and then released them into a crowded area where then the riot police were like chasing them up and down narrow alleys and stuff. And this is a real dilemma action because it creates this like ludicrous scene of absurd
political theater. But, you know, they also couldn't arrest any. literally hurting cats, huh? Exactly. Literally hurting cats, but not able to really figure out who the real protest organizers were. So the Serbian police began to crack down on Odpore. They were arresting the protesters, many of whom were teenagers, and they were also calling the protesters terrorists. But increasingly, it wasn't just young people who were involved. Older people were getting increasingly drawn into the struggle. Why was that? Well, I think that the movement likely did a very good job of appealing to a wider and wider base of supporters. There was a period in which they were experiencing a pretty high degree of police repression.
And I was told by one activist there that they began organizing something called grandparents' protests, which is when they would ask their retired grandparents to come and march or demonstrate with them. And at those marches, they noticed the police were much less likely to start swinging their batons at the crowd. There was just a taboo against beating the elderly in public. And they exploited that taboo. And by the way, also increased their numbers and the diversity of their campaign. What was the final outcome of the protest? Did it work?
It did. Milosevic announced that he was retiring to spend more time with his grandson. He fled. He fled the square. And the movement effectively walked through the line of policemen who obviously were not going to fire on them anymore and occupied the parliament building. And inside, apparently, they found lots of ballots that were premarked for Milosevic. So further demonstrating the fraud. Let's fast forward 20 years and turn from Eastern Europe to Africa.
the country of Sudan was ruled for nearly 30 years by President Omar al-Bashir, who was a brutal dictator. He presided over the genocide in the Darfur region of southern Sudan in the early 2000s. Now, there were periodic uprisings over the years, but the security forces quickly suppressed them. But then in December 2018, protests erupted across the country after the government raised fuel and food prices. The demonstrations were organized by a group called the Sudanese Professional
Association. What were the techniques they used? One of the most important techniques that the SPA was able to organize and mass was a general strike and various other limited strikes and stayaways. And stayaways can be really important for movements that are facing brutal regimes because unlike mass demonstrations, they don't necessarily place people in positions of directly confronting the agents of repression. But in this case, there were also mass demonstrations, sit-ins, marches, protests. They used a really wide range of nonviolent methods in the course of that campaign. So soon after these protests really became widespread, Al-Bashir was actually removed in a coup
and the Sudanese military established a military council. But the SBA kept protesting. They wanted the coup leaders to hand over power to the people and establish a democracy. And this led to something that's now known as the Khartoum massacre. What happened, Erica? Yeah, so what was happening there is that there was a massive sit-in outside of the military headquarters demanding that the civilians be represented in the new government and that a transition to democracy take place as as soon as possible. And various security forces committed a mass atrocity. They killed and sexually assaulted and tortured over 100 people, some of whose bodies they dumped in the Nile River. And in the aftermath of that event, the SPA wisely, I think, called for a general strike and mass
non-cooperation. And the reason I say it was incredibly wise and strategic, is again, it didn't necessarily put people in direct contact with those militias and security forces by calling for a massive 4 million strong demonstration, but instead say nobody's going to work until we have the opportunity to be at the table negotiating a peaceful transition to democracy. And it was a remarkably effective maneuver because not only did it, help to keep people involved and engaged. But it also disrupted the day-to-day order of things
so that the transitional junta didn't feel like it had a way out other than to work with some of the civilian representatives to negotiate an outcome. One of the other lessons that I'm getting from this is that even, you know, highly repressive regimes at some level depend on the, cooperation of the people being repressed in order to hold on to power. And when that cooperation is, is, is, is, uh, withdrawn, it becomes actually quite difficult for even very authoritarian
regimes to hold on to power. That's right. I think that's the, the basic theory. The ruler does depend on so many people to stay in power. Like, they're not doing it themselves. And when very large numbers of people refuse to continue supporting them, things, collapse rather quickly. Movements have to do it. Maria Stephan, as argued, which has extend the nonviolent battlefield into constituencies upon whose cooperation the regime does depend. So that's one kind of tricky factor that explains some variation, I think, in the
outcomes of nonviolent movements. So we've talked about a couple of movements that successfully utilized nonviolent techniques to enact change. I want to look at an example of a lot of. largely nonviolent movement that sometimes dabbled in violence, and it's instructive to see what happened. In May 2011, there was a wave of protests in Spain calling for socioeconomic reform. These were largely peaceful. The movement called itself 15M.
It was named up to May 15th, which is when these demonstrations began. People began occupying central squares in the main cities of Spain, and a large percentage of the public, about 65% supported 15M. Can you tell me what happened in the course of these protests that caused some of them to turn violent and the effects of this turn on public opinion? Basically, there was an episode in which some of the protesters were provoked into using violence in one way or the other. And there were a couple of social scientists who had been conducting surveys on opinions toward the movement before that event took place. and then they were able to do surveys after that event took place as well. And what they found is that the average support for the movement dropped by about 12%
in the aftermath of that event. And the findings were qualified somewhat in the sense that among people who already were very supportive of the movement, there wasn't a very large drop in support. But among people who were kind of, adjacent to the movement politically, who were sympathetic to the movement before, or who were kind of not affiliated with the movement in any way, there was a much bigger decline in support. So in other words, the episode of violence tended to have very little effect on base solidarity, but it had a pretty big effect on alienating potential third-party supporters of the movement
that would have allowed it to expand its base. And so I think the key takeaway of that study is that these types of incidents can be really risky for movements that are trying to expand their base of supporters. And expanding the base of supporters is one of the key things that nonviolent resistance campaigns need to do to win. They need to grow in number and the diversity of their supporters and in the links that their supporters have to different pillars of support. Yeah. So this was worked by the political science. is Jordi Munoz and Eva and Duiza. They happened to be in the area at the time studying 15M,
so they were able to survey the public both before and after, you know, the turn to violence. But I want to stay with this idea for a moment because, you know, I suppose if your base is large enough, if the number of people whom you have on your side is a significant majority, then possibly turning to violence perhaps does not affect the outcome very much because you already have a significant majority on your side. But if you're in a position where you're in a position where,
You know, you are 20% of the population. You really need to recruit a significant number of people to come over to your side in order to make up a majority. And it seems to be in those cases where turning to violence runs the risk of alienating people who might otherwise support you. Yes, that's exactly how I would read kind of the state of the literature on this one, which is that it's a much more risky political move to do when a movement is very small and trying to expand base than it is if a movement is already very large, enjoys a lot of popular support, and critically, the opponent is hated by lots and lots of people. So if it's just a regime that's made so many missteps and has shattered its own legitimacy to such a large extent that, you know,
basically 90% of the population, one where the other wants change, you know, it may be less politically risky. But there still are a lot of risks. One of them is. One of them is just the expansion of repression. It's much more likely to be really intense and to expand indiscriminately when movements do begin to mix nonviolent and violent methods. And that's in part why so many regimes seem to try to deliberately provoke nonviolent movements
into kind of breaking down their discipline because they know that it helps bolster their own legitimacy, see their own calls for the need for law and order and the restoration of stability. And they know that significant portions of the population will largely agree with that. And so, you know, this is part of the reason, you know, why Al-Jolns provocateurs or incidents of repression meant to provoke people out of their discipline are such a ubiquitous part of the autocratic toolkit. It's interesting that I think in these conflicts, you actually have, in some, you actually have,
some ways a test of discipline on both sides because the protesters, nonviolent protesters, are often also trying in some ways to incite the government authorities into overreacting, into cracking down into repression, because I think they also recognize that repression reduces government support. It reduces the legitimacy of government authority, just as the governments might realize that when protest movements resort to violence, it tends to undermine their legitimacy and also undermine their mass appeal? Yes, I think that's a fair comparison. I also think that they're playing a similar game in the sense that they're both trying
从某种程度上说，这也是对双方纪律的一种考验，因为抗议者，也就是非暴力抗议者，往往也在某种程度上试图激起政府当局做出过度反应、强力镇压，因为我认为他们也认识到镇压会减少政府的支持，降低政府当局的合法性。正如政府也可能意识到，当抗议运动诉诸暴力时，往往会削弱其合法性，也会削弱其群众基础。是的，我认为这是一个恰当的比较。我还认为，它们在玩着类似的游戏，因为它们都在试图
to divide and rule the other. So the logic of nonviolent resistance has to grow the base in order to create these defections from the opponent's support base. So basically, you know, the movement is effectively trying to divide the opponent and dislocate it from its pillars of support. and that, you know, the regime is trying to do the same to the movement. So we've looked at a few examples of cases where people used violence or nonviolence or a combination of these tactics to try and enact change.
分而治之对方。因此，非暴力抗争的逻辑必须扩大基础，以便从对手的支持基础中制造出叛逃。所以基本上，你知道，这场运动实际上是在试图分裂对手并将其从支持支柱中剥离出来。你知道，政权也在试图对运动做同样的事情。因此，我们看了一些人们使用暴力、非暴力或这些策略的结合来试图实现变革的案例。
And obviously the specifics of each conflict are unique. And cataloging conflicts as violent or nonviolent probably involves some judgment. Things may not be entirely, you know, black and white. But when you step back and look at the big picture of examples of both violent and nonviolent protest movements over the span of the 20th century, what did you and Maria find? Well, the basic descriptive statistic that really jumped out is that the nonviolent campaigns were twice as likely to have succeeded as their violent counterparts,
显而易见，每场冲突的具体细节都是独一无二的。将冲突分类为暴力或非暴力可能涉及一些判断。事情可能并非完全非黑即白。但是，当你退一步，纵观20世纪暴力和非暴力抗议运动的宏观大局时，你和玛丽亚发现了什么？嗯，最突出的基本描述性统计数据是，非暴力运动成功的可能性是其暴力对手的两倍，
and that the rates of success for nonviolent campaigns had actually increased over the latter half of the 20th century and into the beginning of the 21st. So in other words, nonviolent campaigns, resistance was working much more than skeptics like myself would have expected. At the same time, that doesn't mean that it worked all the time. We found basically that about around half of the cases that we studied had succeeded, and about 25% of the cases of armed resistance had succeeded. And so, you know, we also would never argue that that violent resistance never works,
而且非暴力运动的成功率在20世纪下半叶到21世纪初实际上有所上升。换句话说，非暴力运动、抗争的作用远超像我这样的怀疑论者的预期。同时，这并不意味着它永远管用。我们基本上发现，在我们研究的案例中，大约有一半成功了，而武装抵抗的案例中大约有25%成功了。所以，你知道，我们也绝不会争辩说暴力抵抗永远不管用，
because clearly one out of four cases had succeeded as well. So never the, you know, never, Nevertheless, I at least was very surprised by the fact of this, and it definitely motivated us to continue trying to figure out why. When we come back, the subtle psychological mechanisms that explain why nonviolent movements might seem less likely to succeed than violent campaigns, but end up being more effective in the long term. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham.
因为显然四分之一的案例也成功了。尽管如此，至少我对这一事实感到非常惊讶，它绝对激励我们继续试图弄清楚原因。稍后回来，我们将探讨细微的心理机制，这些机制解释了为什么非暴力运动看起来不如暴力运动成功率高，但最终在长期内却更有效。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Harvard University, political scientist Erica Chenowit studies the effectiveness of political protest. Along with Maria Stephan, Erica has studied more than 100 years of struggles for radical change around the world. These included both violent and nonviolent revolutions and insurrections. They found that nonviolent campaigns were twice as likely to succeed as violent campaigns. Violent forms of protest might get a lot of press and attention, but they tend to invite harsh repression from authorities
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在哈佛大学，政治学家埃里卡·切诺维思研究政治抗争的有效性。埃里卡与玛丽亚·斯蒂芬一起，研究了世界各地超过100年的激进变革斗争。这些斗争包括暴力和非暴力革命与起义。他们发现，非暴力运动成功的可能性是暴力运动的两倍。暴力形式的抗议可能会获得大量的媒体关注，但它们往往会招致当局的严厉镇压，
and also to turn off potential allies. Erica and Maria have discovered four key factors that explain why nonviolent movements appear to be increasingly more effective than violent insurrections. The first factor is mass participation. So movements that win tend to be much larger and more diverse than movements that don't. And nonviolent campaigns tend to be able to elicit
并且也会疏远潜在的盟友。埃里卡和玛丽亚发现了四个关键因素，解释了为什么非暴力运动似乎比暴力起义越来越有效。第一个因素是大规模参与。因此，取得胜利的运动往往比没有取得胜利的运动规模更大、更多元化。而非暴力运动往往能够引发
much larger and more diverse participation than armed campaigns. The second factor is the ability of the campaigns to divide and rule the opponent by shifting the loyalties of people within various pillars of support. So the larger the base becomes for a movement, the more likely it is that participants in the movement will have direct ties to people in the opponent's pillars of support, like economic and business elites, important politicians, civil servants, state media, different types of police or security forces
比武装运动更大、更多元化的参与。第二个因素是运动通过转移各种支持支柱内人们的忠诚度来分而治之对手的能力。因此，一项运动的基础越大，运动参与者与对手支持支柱中的人（如经济和商业精英、重要政客、公务员、国家媒体、不同类型的警察或安全部队
or other authorities, local government and local authorities. And the more of those connections begin to be embedded within the movement, the more likely it is that the movement can maneuver in ways that begin to really shred the loyalties of people in those pillars of support. The third factor is the ability of movements to tactically innovate, especially moving away from mass demonstrations, rallies, and protests, and more into forms of non-cooperation, like strikes, stay at homes, and kind of undermining power for the opponent. And that's really the main thing is that these movements aren't out there to like melt the heart of the dictator, you know? they're out there to remove the bases of the dictator's support. So that's a really key distinction. And I think is probably what leads a lot of people to think that nonviolent resistance campaigns are naive,
或其他当局、地方政府和地方当局）建立直接联系的可能性就越大。这些联系越多地融入到运动中，运动就越有可能采取能够真正瓦解这些支持支柱中人们忠诚度的方式进行运作。第三个因素是运动进行战术创新的能力，特别是摆脱大规模示威、集会和抗议，转向更多形式的不合作，如罢工、闭门不出，以及削弱对手的权力。这确实是最主要的事情，因为这些运动并不是为了融化独裁者的心，你知道吗？
is that they think they're trying to change the mind of a brutal dictator when they're not. They're trying to win a political fight among people who are neutral, who are kind of sympathetic to the regime but not actively supporting. it and certainly among people that are sympathetic to the movement but not actively supporting it. And then the fourth factor that seems to be really important is for the movement to be able to develop some kind of organizational resilience and discipline so that when or if repression escalates, that the movement is able to continue to recruit, to continue to maneuver as it needs to without falling into disarray. And often what disarray means is, you know, some people
它们是为了移除独裁者支持的基础。所以这是一个非常关键的区别。我认为这很可能是导致许多人认为非暴力抗争运动很天真的原因，
start to say we need to use violence now and they just go do that, you know, without any kind of organizational cohesion. And so we know that organizational cohesion leads to lots of things that help movements, including discipline. So I just want to go back to one of the points you made. The idea that in some ways the central goal of these movements is to expand their base of support, to bring more people in, to sort of feel like the movement is a mass movement. Talk a little bit about the work that you've done that examines how large a movement needs to be in order to be effective. Because when I saw this, I was actually struck by in some ways how small that number actually needs to be. Right. Maria, Stefan and I analyzed about 323 cases. of maximalist campaigns or revolutionary campaigns.
是因为他们认为这些运动试图改变一个残暴独裁者的想法，而事实并非如此。他们试图在那些中立的、对政权抱有同情但并不积极支持的人中间，以及当然在那些对运动抱有同情但并不积极支持的人中间，赢得一场政治斗争。然后，第四个因素似乎非常重要，那就是运动能够发展某种组织弹性和纪律，以便在镇压升级时或升级的情况下，运动能够继续招募人员，根据需要继续运作而不会陷入混乱。通常混乱意味着，你知道，有些人
And I found that none of the campaigns seem to have failed after mobilizing three and a half percent of the population. And three and a half percent is a small number in relative terms, but very large and absolute terms. So in the United States, that's like 11.5 million people in China. It's many tens of millions of people. And so then we start to get a sense of the scale.
开始说我们现在需要使用暴力，然后他们就去这么做了，你知道，没有任何形式的组织凝聚力。因此，我们知道组织凝聚力会带来很多有助于运动的事物，包括纪律。我只想回到你提出的一个观点。在某种程度上，这些运动的核心目标是扩大其支持基础，吸引更多人进来，让人感觉这场运动是一场群众运动。请谈谈你所做的工作，该工作探讨了运动需要多大规模才能有效。因为当我看到这个时，我实际上对这个数字在某种程度上实际上需要多小感到震惊。对的。玛丽亚·斯蒂芬和我分析了大约323个极端主义运动或革命运动的案例。
It's worth pausing for a moment and sitting with that finding. Erica found that movements that mobilized about three and a half percent of the population succeeded pretty much everywhere. But before you think it's easy to organize and execute a mass movement for change, Erica has a few caveats about that data point. That it only counts participation. It doesn't necessarily look at supporters of the movement or sympathizers with the movement. And so it can be easy to sort of conclude
我发现，在动员了3.5%的人口之后，似乎没有任何运动失败过。3.5%相对而言是个小数字，但在绝对数量上非常巨大。因此，在美国，这就相当于1150万人，在中国，则是数千万甚至上亿人。因此，我们开始对这个规模有了一个概念。
I think wrongly that all you need is three and a half percent of the population on your side. I don't think that's what the data say. It says that, you know, countries in which there have been three and a half percent of the population actively mobilized at a sort of peak period are extremely unlikely to lose. But that could be because they have already elicited like 90 percent of the population's support or, you know, something along those lines. So the way that I think about the 3.5% rule is really more of a rule of thumb rather than an iron law. So those are the unknowns that make me cautious about kind of over interpreting the rule.
值得停下来思考一下这个发现。埃里卡发现，动员了大约3.5%人口的运动几乎在所有地方都取得了成功。但在你认为组织和执行大规模变革运动很容易之前，埃里卡对这个数据点有一些警告。即它只计算了参与度。它不一定着眼于运动的支持者或同情者。因此很容易得出这样的结论：
I want to look at one other idea, which is in some ways violence sort of produces its own opposition. So the harsher you behave, yes, on the one hand, you do get compliance and people do fall in line. people are afraid of you. But it's also the case that violence generates enemies. You have more enemies tomorrow than you did yesterday. And over time, you can see how it's effective in the short term, but it can end up having great costs for your campaign in the long term. Yeah. I mean, I think one helpful way to think about this is to think about tactical effects versus strategic outcomes. So if you think about that event that took place in Spain with the 15M movement, the short-term effects of those types of events are often really obvious.
我想这是错误的，即你只需要3.5%的人口站在你这一边。我认为数据并非如此。它表明，你知道，在峰值时期有3.5%的人口被积极动员的国家极不可能失败。但这可能是因为他们已经获得了90%的人口的支持，或者类似的情况。因此，我认为3.5%法则是大拇指法则（经验法则），而不是铁律。所以正是这些未知因素让我对过度解读这一法则保持谨慎。
It's things like greater media coverage. Like maybe they wound up on the front page rather than on the 20th page or something of the newspaper. Maybe, you know, there was a self-defense justification. And so somebody was able to get away from that. that event who otherwise would have been beaten up by someone. You know, there are, you know, short-term tactical reasons why people often say, see that violence helped. But then if you look at the long-term strategic outcomes, it also has really important after effects. For example, the expansion of repression against people who are involved in the movement or their family
我想看另一个观点，即暴力在某种程度上会产生自己的对立面。因此，你的行为越严厉，一方面，你确实能得到顺从，人们也确实会听从指挥，人们怕你。但同样的情况是，暴力会产生敌人。你明天拥有的敌人比昨天更多。随着时间的推移，你可以看到它在短期内是如何有效的，但从长远来看，它最终可能会给你的运动带来巨大的代价。是的。我的意思是，思考这个问题的一个有用的方法是考虑战术效果与战略结果。因此，如果你想想在西班牙发生的那个15M运动的事件，这类事件的短期效果通常是非常明显的。
members, whether they participated in the violence or not. It often has the effect of then expanding government powers of surveillance and infiltration and other types of things that actually are really challenging for movements to manage. And then, you know, sometimes it alienates would-be supporters and often creates a sense of unity and camaraderie among security forces, for example, rather than encouraging them to take a moment and think about what they think is going on in the country. So, yeah, I mean, I think most of what we know about incident of violence is that it does harden the opposition rather than kind of softening the opposition and allowing it to fracture. This is part of why a lot of the research, for example, on the impacts
比如获得更多的媒体报道。比如也许他们最终上了头版，而不是报纸的第二版或其他什么地方。也许，你知道，存在正当防卫的理由。因此，某个原本会被其他人殴打的人能够从那个事件中脱身。你知道，有一些短期战术上的原因，为什么人们经常说，看，暴力有帮助。但如果你看看长期的战略结果，它也会产生非常重要的后续影响。例如，对参与运动的人或其家属的镇压升级
of terrorism on a political system are that it's very polarizing. But it generally leads the population to embrace more right-wing political beliefs about what the government ought to be able to do to restore public order. So what's fascinating to me, Erica, is that the government is that that, you know, our model, our mental model, I think, is still stuck in sort of what we see in on television or in the movies, you know, where we see that violent, you know, people who have been unjustly, you know, treated, resort to violence in order to get justice, or we see that groups that basically want their way, sort of use violence to win. I'm not sure it's sort of a concerted effort to look the other way, but there really does seem to be a reluctance to grapple with
成员，无论他们是否参与了暴力。它往往会产生扩大政府监控、渗透和其他实际上对运动管理极具挑战性的权力的效果。然后，你知道，有时它会疏远潜在的支持者，并往往在安全部队中产生一种团结和同志情谊，而不是鼓励他们花时间思考他们认为国家正在发生的事情。所以，是的，我的意思是，我们对暴力事件的大多数了解是，它确实会使反对派强硬起来，而不是软化反对派并使其分裂。这也是为什么很多关于恐怖主义对政治系统影响的研究表明它极具极化性的原因之一，
with these histories in a way that at least commensurate with the way we think about conventional military histories. Yeah, I think part of it is just basic misconceptions and myths about what nonviolent resistance is. For example, when people use the term nonviolence, I think that they often just associate that with a moral position. And they think of it as something that's potentially noble, but extremely naive. You know, they don't think. think about it in terms of a strategy that's literally helped to shape the world we live in right now, and that's available to anybody anywhere to a certain degree. There's an interesting book called Recovering Nonviolent History that's edited by Mace Barkowski.
但它通常会导致公众接受更多关于政府应该能够做些什么来恢复公共秩序的右翼政治信仰。所以对我来说迷人的是，埃里卡，政府是——我们的大脑模型，我认为，仍然停留在我们在电视或电影中看到的那种情景中，你知道，在那里我们看到暴力的人，那些受到不公正待遇的人，诉诸暴力以获得正义，或者我们看到那些基本上想要随心所欲的集团，利用暴力来取胜。我不确定这是否是一种刻意视而不见的努力，但确实似乎有一种不愿意面对
And there's an opening chapter in there about the myth of violence and how sort of appealing it is and how we memorialize it and mythologize it and make it part of our national histories, But that book is full of examples of nonviolent campaigns that were formative in developing nations around the world, including in the United States. So one of the chapters is actually a look at the American Revolution by Walter Kanser. And in it, he argues that actually the most important part of the American Revolution came in the 10 years before armed hostilities broke out, where colonists were affected. using all kinds of different forms of economic non-cooperation and the development of alternative institutions like alternative judicial institutions,
这些历史的意愿，其程度至少与我们思考传统军事历史的方式不相称。是的，我认为部分原因只是关于非暴力抗争是什么的基本误解和神话。例如，当人们使用非暴力这个词时，我认为他们往往只将其与道德立场联系起来。他们认为这是一种潜在高尚但极其天真的事情。你知道，他们不认为它是以一种字面意义上塑造了我们现在生活的世界的战略来思考的，而且在一定程度上，它对世界上任何人、在任何地方都是可用的。有一本有趣的书叫《恢复非暴力历史》，由梅斯·巴科夫斯基编辑。
political conventions, and other things that otherwise would not be really allowed in a monarchy. And they effectively freed themselves, so to speak, before the hostilities broke out. And in fact, if you tell the story that way, the war that took place between the colonists and the British was actually the counter-revolution. It was the attempt by the British to seize back
里面有一开篇章节讲的是暴力的神话，以及它是多么吸引人，我们是如何纪念它、神话化它并将其作为我们国家历史的一部分的，但那书里充满了非暴力运动的例子，这些运动在世界各地（包括美国）的发展中国家中起到了塑造作用。因此，其中一章实际上是沃尔特·坎瑟对美国革命的考察。在其中，他认为实际上美国革命最重要部分发生在武装冲突爆发前的10年里，当时殖民地居民正在
what they thought was rightfully theirs after the Declaration of Independence took place. So in a way, there's a real need to, I think, recover some of the histories of nonviolent resistance that have defined our countries, our nations, our world, and that were sort of the inheritors of, but don't know it. Before we recorded this conversation, I had never heard the argument that the most important part of the American Revolution
使用各种不同形式的经济不合作以及另类机构的发展，如另类司法机构、政治大会以及在君主制下本来不会真正被允许的其他事情。可以说，他们在冲突爆发前就有效地解放了自己。事实上，如果你这样讲述这个故事，殖民地居民与英国人之间发生的战争实际上是一场反革命。那是英国人在《独立宣言》发表后试图重新夺回
occurred in the ten years before armed hostilities broke out. When we think of revolutions, we tend to remember the drama of soldiers heading off to war, the outcomes of battles fought on land and sea, guns and guillotine. Bloodshed has a way of imprinting itself on our minds. As the years pass, it's easy to forget about all the work that occurs in the years before a revolution begins. The slow building of alliances, the quiet refusal to abide by unfair laws. The arguments and counter-arguments debated in newspapers and on social media. That earlier phase of resistance may be quiet, but it requires a trait that, much like non-violent resistance itself, is frequently misunderstood.
他们认为在独立宣言发表后理应属于他们的东西。因此，在某种程度上，我认为确实非常需要恢复那些定义了我们的国家、我们的民族、我们的世界，而我们虽然是其继承者却一无所知的非暴力抗争历史。在我们录制这次对话之前，我从未听说过这样的论点，即美国革命最重要的一部分
Courage. We often think of courage as a personality trait. You either have it or you don't. But researchers are finding that courage can be cultivated. in moments of reflection where we think through who we are and what matters most to us. The laying of our inner groundwork is what allows us to act bravely
发生在武装冲突爆发前的十年里。当我们想到革命时，我们倾向于记住士兵奔赴战场时的戏剧性、在陆地和海上进行的战斗结果、枪支和断头台。流血事件有一种在我们心中留下印记的方式。随着时间的推移，很容易忘记在革命开始前几年所发生的所有工作。缓慢建立联盟，对不公正法律的默默拒绝。在报纸和社交媒体上争论不休的论点和反论点。那早期的抗争阶段可能是安静的，但它需要一种特质，这种特质就像非暴力抗争本身一样，经常被误解。
when a crisis is upon us. After the break, stories of times where our courage is tested and what they teach us about the true nature of bravery. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all have to deal with scary situations. There may be moments of high drama, like a car crash or a natural disaster. Or perhaps we will have moments of personal crisis, like navigating a serious illness
勇气。我们经常把勇气视为一种人格特质。要么你有，要么你没有。但研究人员发现，勇气是可以培养的。在反思的时刻，我们思考自己是谁以及什么对我们最重要。我们内心基础的奠定，正是我们在危机降临时的勇敢行为
or sharing a painful truth with a loved one. We'd like to think that we will face these moments bravely. But will we actually rise to the occasion? At Harvard Business School, Ranjay Gulati studies courage and how we can strengthen our own capacity to be brave. Ranjee joined us recently for two episodes on this topic. The first was titled U2.0, Cultivating Courage. And the second, on Hidden Brain Plus, was called U2.0, How to Help Others Be Brave.
的基础。休息过后，将播出考验我们勇气的时刻的故事，以及它们教给我们关于勇敢的真实本质的知识。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都要应对可怕的情况。可能会有高潮迭起的时刻，比如车祸或自然灾害。或者我们可能会面临个人危机的时刻，比如应对重大的疾病
You can find both those episodes in this podcast feed. Today, Ranjay returns to the show to answer listener questions about this topic. Ranjay, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's a pleasure to be back. One story that you cite Ranjay is of the Russian disqualification. President politician Alexi Navalny. Tell me his story. You know, Navaldi is a kind of a very interesting story and it follows a very interesting arc as well. He starts as an anti-corruption
或是与挚爱分享一个痛苦的真相。我们愿意认为自己会勇敢地面对这些时刻。但我们真的能不负众望吗？在哈佛商学院，兰杰·古拉提研究勇气以及我们如何能够增强自己保持勇敢的能力。兰杰最近和我们一起录制了关于这个主题的两期节目。第一期名为《U2.0：培养勇气》。第二期在《隐藏的大脑Plus》上，名为《U2.0：如何帮助他人变得勇敢》。
lawyer, critical of power, but still within the system. And he then decides that he's really going to pivot from there into exposing corruption at the highest levels, you know, and he then becomes part of the opposition story here. And then things really rampant. up for him. Arrest, harassment, assassination attempt. And, you know, with a very deadly poison, they evacuate him, evacuate him to Germany, and miraculously they're able to save him. This was considered very unlikely, but he does. But really what is most interesting and actually in the end, tragic, is he returns back to Russia, knowing fully well that when he lands, they are likely to arrest him and he may not make it out alive after this.
你可以在这个播客源中找到这两期节目。今天，兰杰重返节目，回答听众关于这个主题的提问。兰杰，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能回来。你引用的一个故事是关于俄罗斯取消资格的。总统政治家阿列克谢·纳瓦尔尼。跟我讲讲他的故事。你知道，纳瓦尔尼是一个非常有趣的故事，它也遵循了一个非常有趣的弧线。他最初是一名反腐败律师，对权力持批评态度，但仍然在体制之内。然后他决定真正从那里转向揭露最高层的腐败，你知道，然后他成为了这里反对派故事的一部分。然后事情真的为他急速升温。逮捕、骚扰、暗杀未遂。而且，你知道，用致命的毒药，他们把他撤离，撤离到德国，奇迹般地他们能够救他。这被认为是非常不可能的，但他做到了。但真正最有趣且最终是悲剧的是，他返回了俄罗斯，心里非常清楚，当他落地时，他们很可能会逮捕他，而且他可能无法活着离开。
But he chooses to do that. What happens when he goes back? Well, he's arrested right at the airport, then transported to Siberia, put into one of the worst prisons over there, is in solitary for long periods of time, and ultimately he passes away over there. He's periodically allowed to meet people,
但他还是选择了这么做。他回去后会发生什么？好吧，他刚下飞机就被逮捕了，然后被送到西伯利亚，关进当地最糟糕的监狱之一，被长期单独关禁闭，最终他在那里去世了。他偶尔被允许见人，
and so there are recordings of him while he's there, even shortly before his death, he writes, he talks, and he's still making his point. He still wants to get the point out there that, listen, giving up is not an option. And it somehow fits into what we call the hero's journey. The hero leaves safety to serve a higher truth. And in this case, the hero's journey doesn't have to lead to a happy ending,
所以他在那里时留下了录音，甚至在他去世前不久，他还在写作、交谈，并且仍在表达自己的观点。他仍然想向世人表明：听着，放弃绝不是一种选择。这在某种程度上契合了我们所说的英雄之旅。英雄离开安全区去践行更高的真理。在这种情况下，英雄之旅并不一定要有一个美好的结局，
but it does promise a meaningful ending you know and in this case you know you see it's not like a victory for him he succeeds but it's kind of a moral ending you know he has made a choice
但它确实承诺了一个有意义的结局，你知道的，在这种情况下，你看，这对他来说不像是某种胜利，他成功了，但这是一种道义上的结局，你知道的，他做出了一个选择，
that he is going to live his life in alignment with his beliefs and principles and it is something that he will do even if it costs him his life what I like about hero's journey and the whole idea there is that
决定按照自己的信念和原则生活，即使付出生命的代价，他也会坚持这么做。我喜欢英雄之旅以及其中整个理念的原因在于，
because it kind of normalizes fear and struggle it tells us that doubt doesn't disqualify us and transformation is possible you don't have to be perfect and you don't even have to get it always right but a moral overtone just makes it much more kind of compelling
因为它将恐惧和挣扎常规化了，它告诉我们，怀疑并不能否定我们，转变是有可能的。你不需要完美，甚至不需要每次都做对，但道德基调会让这一切变得更加引人入胜，
because you are now on a quest you could be on a quest for physical endurance you know running or doing a cross-country marathon of some sorts or some kind of, that is also a hero's journey whereas the challenge is a physical one, but others are like a Navalny story, is one of a moral pursuit as well.
因为你现在踏上了一段探险之旅。你可能是在进行一场对体能极限的探险，比如跑步或进行某种越野马拉松之类的，或者某种挑战体能的英雄之旅；但其他的就像纳瓦利内那样，也是对道德的一种追求。
You know, when I hear the word hero's journey, I think I was mistakenly focused on the word journey. So Navalny, of course, travels a lot. He goes from one place to the other. There are many stories of these epic journeys involve, you know, a warrior traveling from one place to the other. But really, the journey that is being described is an internal journey. It's the internal journey from someone who might have been hesitant or diffident to the discovery of one's own courage. That is the journey that is the hero's journey.
你知道的，当我听到“英雄之旅”这个词时，我想我之前错误地把重点放在了“之旅”这个词上。所以纳瓦利内当然到处旅行。他从一个地方走到另一个地方。许多史诗般的旅程的故事都涉及到勇士从一个地方旅行到另一个地方。但实际上，这里所描述的旅程是一段内心的旅程。这是一段从可能有些犹豫或羞怯转变为发现自身勇气的内心旅程。这才是真正的英雄之旅。
In many instances, it's something about your own commitment to a set of values or principles that go beyond self-interest and a willingness to incur cost. and no matter what that might be for that set of principles. People have also called this felt responsibility. You somehow believe that this is such an important piece for you and that violation of those values and principles feels more threatening than personal risk. And so instead of asking the question,
在很多情况下，这与你对超越自我利益的一套价值观或原则的承诺有关，以及你愿意为此付出的代价，无论这种代价对于这套价值观而言可能意味着什么。人们也将此称为“切身体会到的责任感”。你莫名地觉得这对你来说是如此重要，以至于违背这些价值观和原则比个人风险更让人感到威胁。因此，与其去问这样一个问题：
then in the situation, instead of asking like, oh my God, what's the smartest or safest thing? I can do here, you ask the question, what kind of person am I willing to be? Is it in alignment? You know, you saw that story about Australia where this storekeeper sees two people shooting into a crowd during a Hanukkah celebration. He said, I didn't have a choice. I had to do something. That's the person I am. And he got shot, you know, he may never fully recover. But for him, His personal belief about himself was more important to him than physical safety even. I want to play you a question from a listener that perhaps complicates one dimension of our account of a hero's journey.
在这种情况下，与其去想：天哪，我在这里能做的最聪明或最安全的事情是什么？不如去问：我愿意成为一个什么样的人？这符合我的信念吗？你看，你看到过澳大利亚的那个故事，有个店主看到两个人在光明节庆祝活动中向人群开枪。他说：“我别无选择。我必须做点什么。我就是这样的人。”结果他中枪了，你知道的，他可能永远也无法完全康复。但对他来说，他对自己内心的信念甚至比身体的安全更重要。我想播放一位听众的提问，这个问题或许让我们的英雄之旅概念变得更加复杂。
This message comes from listener, Suzanne. Courage in my life has often not felt like a decision at all. It has felt like a kind of inner knowing that simply moved my body forward, before my mind could argue. One moment stands out vividly. My son was only six months old. My husband and I were walking into a restaurant and I was holding my baby. I saw a very large man assaulting a very petite woman outside. I don't remember thinking at all. I simply handed my baby to my husband and said, please take him. Then I walked straight up to this man and told him very clearly to stop. I told someone else to call 911. The police came and the man was arrested.
这条留言来自听众苏珊。我生活中的勇气往往一点也不像是一个决定。它感觉像是一种内在的直觉，在我的大脑来得及争辩之前，就简单地推动着我的身体向前。有一个时刻让我记忆犹新。我儿子当时只有六个月大。我和丈夫正走进一家餐馆，我怀里抱着孩子。我看到一个身材高大壮硕的男子在外面殴打一个非常娇小的女性。我甚至不记得自己有没有思考过。我只是把孩子塞给丈夫，说：请照顾好他。然后我径直走到这个男人面前，非常明确地告诉他住手。我叫另一个人拨打911。警察来了，那个人被捕了。
There was no planning, no courage narrative in my head. Something deeper moved me. I've learned that when we listen to that inner knowing, whether we call it intuition, conscience, or soul, we often discover we are capable of far more than we imagined. So, Ranjay Suzanne tells us, over and over that she didn't think through her actions. She just acted. Do you think it's possible that when we label someone's story as a hero's journey, we are doing that after the fact that in the moment bravery may in fact be impulsive? Absolutely. You know, there is what you might call, you know, even in psychology, we talk about system one, the fast emotional response and system two that is a more slow and reflective response. And yes, it is true.
没有计划，脑子里也没有关于勇气的宏大叙事。某种更深层次的东西触动了我。我了解到，当我们倾听内心的直觉——无论是称之为直觉、良知还是灵魂——我们经常会发现，我们的潜能远超想象。所以，兰杰，苏珊一再告诉我们，她并没有权衡自己的行动。她只是付诸行动。你认为有没有可能，当我们给某人的故事贴上“英雄之旅”的标签时，我们是在事后才这样做的？在当时的那一刻，勇敢实际上可能是一种冲动？完全有可能。你知道的，在心理学中，甚至有一种说法，我们谈论系统一，即快速的情绪反应，以及系统二，即更慢、更反思的反应。确实如此，
that some of our responses, the fight, flight, freeze response are automatic and fight is one of the three. And somehow, sometimes, some things trigger us to fight because most of the time it is freeze or flee. But I would submit to you that, you know, clearly she felt a sense of outrage
我们的一些反应，即战斗、逃跑、僵住的反应是自动的，而战斗是这三种反应之一。不知何故，有时某些事情会触发我们去战斗，因为大多数时候我们的反应是僵住或逃跑。但我认为，很明显她当时感受到了强烈的情绪，
and that, you know, while she may not have fully cognitively processed it and she may have experienced it as instinctive, there was definitely a sense of outrage and a sense of empathy. So empathy for the recipient, we know, makes us more likely to take action. There are also a condition where nobody else is doing anything. So you realize that you are the only recourse over here. And so you choose to take action because of that.
虽然她可能没有完全在认知上处理好这一过程，并且她可能将其体验为一种本能，但其中绝对存在一种义愤填膺之感以及同理心。我们知道，对受害者的同理心会让我们更有可能采取行动。还有一种情况是，当时没有其他人采取任何行动。所以你意识到自己是这里唯一的求助对象。正因如此，你选择采取行动。
But to me, what is also interesting is her recounting of this story. when we have experiences like this it's what we have also called mastery experiences it's what we learn that sometimes you learn by acting and then reflecting so some some would argue you can't teach courage by telling people to be brave you teach it by helping them act and then reflect
但在我看来，同样有趣的是她对这个故事的复述。当我们有这样的经历时，这就是我们所说的“精熟体验”。有时你会通过行动然后反思来学习——所以有些人会争辩说，你不能通过告诉人们要勇敢来教授勇气，而是要通过帮助他们行动然后反思来教会他们。
and when they act and reflect they realize oh I did it I can do this and by the way this is an alignment with who I am But I love the fact that she remembers the story because I think that story, probably I would hypothesize, really changed her forever. It was a transformative experience for her. It's also the case, as I'm reflecting on what you're saying, Ranjay, that there are probably different kinds of situations that call for different kinds of courage. So in this situation, in fact, the courage that was called for was immediate and instinctive. But that's not always the case.
当他们行动并反思时，他们会意识到：噢，我做到了，我能行。而且顺便说一句，这与我是什么样的人是一致的。但我很喜欢她能记住这个故事，因为我认为这个故事——我猜想——真的永远改变了她。这对她来说是一次具有变革意义的经历。兰杰，正如我对你所说的话的反思一样，情况也可能是这样的：可能存在不同类型的情况，需要不同类型的勇气。所以在这个情境中，实际上所需要的勇气是即时且出于本能的。但并非总是如此。
There are many, many situations that we have where, in fact, deliberate thinking is important. It's actually important for us to ask what is the courageous thing for me to do, to be deliberate about it. And in some ways, that is just as much an act of bravery as the instinctive, sudden, impulsive act of courage. It's a great question. So I would distinguish between acute bravery, which is the moment in that moment, short term, right? or an enduring bravery or long-term bravery, which is quieter and often harder. Because it shows up as persistence, endurance,
我们遇到了许许多多这样的情况：事实上，深思熟虑非常重要。对我们来说，去思考什么是勇敢的做法，并对此进行审慎的思考，其实是很重要的。在某些情况下，这同样也是一种勇敢的行为，不亚于本能的、突然的、冲动的勇气之举。这是一个很棒的问题。因此，我会将“急性勇敢”（也就是那个时刻的、短期的勇敢，对吧）与“持久勇敢”或“长期勇敢”区分开来，后者更为沉静，通常也更艰难。因为它表现为坚持、忍耐、
recommitment, you know, kind of holding on to unpopular positions, living with uncertainty and still remaining aligned with your values. You know, Navalny's life journey unfolded not in an instinctive moment, but over a period of many years. and at any moment
再次承诺，你知道的，也就是坚持不受欢迎的立场，与不确定性共存，同时依然保持与自己的价值观一致。你知道，纳瓦利内的人生旅程并不是在某个本能的瞬间展开的，而是在长达数年的时间里展开的。而且在任何时刻，
I'm sure there was temptation to give up so short term bravely often relies upon adrenaline moral clarity or kind of a surge of emotion long-term bravery I think relies more on meaning identity self-regulation
我确信都会有放弃的诱惑。因此，短期的勇敢通常依赖于肾上腺素、道德清晰度或某种情绪的激增；而长期的勇敢，我认为更多地依赖于意义、认同感和自我调节，
the ability to kind of I would say tolerate discomfort without burning out or even becoming cynical so I think We have to kind of think of these two working in consonants with each other. When we come back, a man cheats death in rural China, plus how the nature versus nurture debate plays out in the context of courage. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
也就是我所说的忍受不适的能力，同时又不会精疲力竭甚至变得愤世嫉俗。所以我认为，我们必须将这两种品质视为彼此协调发挥作用。稍后回来，一个中国农村男子死里逃生，此外，先天与后天的辩论如何在勇气的语境中展开。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ranji Gulati is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He studies the science of courage and what makes some people act bravely in a scary or dangerous situation. Ranjay, we talked in our earlier conversation about the importance of self-efficacy in shaping our capacity to be brave. What do you mean by this term?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。兰杰·古拉蒂是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。他研究勇气的科学，以及是什么让一些人在可怕或危险的情况下表现得勇敢。兰杰，我们在之前的交谈中讨论过自我效能感在塑造我们勇敢能力方面的重要性。你这个词是什么意思？
So self-efficacy was a term that famous Stanford psychologist Albert Bendora really put forward. And the idea was around that you have confidence in your own ability to take action. I think self-efficacy then transatlanticity then transcends into a larger can-do mindset.
所以“自我效能感”是著名的斯坦福心理学家阿尔伯特·班杜拉真正提出的一个术语。其核心理念是，你对自己的行动能力充满信心。我认为自我效能感随后会转化为一种更大的“能行”的心态。
I would call this the spillover effect. And there's really good research on this. Self-perception theory, for instance, suggests that we figure out who we are by watching what we do. And so when we act courageously in one domain, say taking up a new sport, you know, you prove to yourself that I'm somebody
我称之为“溢出效应”。这方面有非常棒的研究。例如，自我知觉理论表明，我们通过观察自己的行为来弄清楚自己是谁。因此，当我们在一个领域表现得勇敢时，比如尝试一项新运动，你知道的，你向自己证明了“我是一个
who can try hard things and that travels with us into other aspects of what we do. So you don't just do a brave thing. You actually are becoming a braver person. Because you start to believe that self-belief you update in your own mind. The internal narrative that we have shifts from, I avoid hard things to I'm someone who can face them. And so I firmly believe that people don't just do brave things. When they do, they become braver people. We got an interesting question from a listener about how
能够迎接艰难挑战的人”，这种心态会伴随我们进入我们所做的其他事情中。所以你不仅仅是做了一件勇敢的事。你实际上正在成为一个更勇敢的人。因为你开始相信这种自我信念，你在自己心中更新了这种信念。我们内心的叙事从“我回避困难的事情”转变为“我是能够面对困难的人”。因此，我坚信人们不只是在做勇敢的事。当他们这样做时，他们会变成更勇敢的人。我们收到了一位听众关于以下问题的有趣提问：
much bravery is learned and how much it's innate. Here's listener Talgat. Is being brave something that people acquire over time or is it natural ability or is it a mix of both? I'm asking this because I have three children and I try to nurture them at the same time, at the same way. However, one of my children He's extremely brave. It looks like he doesn't have his part of the brain that's responsible for being cautious. And this is not something that I taught him.
多少勇气是后天习得的，多少是天生的。这位是听众塔尔加特。勇敢是人们随时间推移获得的东西，还是天生的能力，亦或是两者的结合？我问这个问题是因为我有三个孩子，我试着以相同的时间、相同的方式去培养他们。然而，其中一个孩子却极其勇敢。看起来他身上好像缺少了负责谨慎的那部分大脑。这不是我教给他的。
So I'm curious about what do you think? What do you think, Ranjay? Does courage come from nature or from nature? So Tolga asked a great question. And this gets to the heart of my project. I mean, if there was only nature, then I didn't have. much to write about. My entire book is premised on the idea that maybe there are a set of practices that we can learn. But it's not some kind of classroom skill. You can't teach people courage by saying,
所以我很好奇你是怎么想的？兰杰，你怎么看？勇气是来自天性还是后天培养？塔尔加特问了一个很好的问题。这触及了我这个项目的核心。我的意思是，如果只有天性，那我也没有太多可写的了。我的整本书都建立在这样一个理念之上：也许存在一套我们可以学习的做法。但这并不是某种课堂上的技能。你不能通过这样的话来教导人们勇气：
come on, from tomorrow you're going to be brave. We teach it by helping them act and then reflect. So we don't teach them by telling them who from tomorrow be fearless or deal with fear. We sort of make them prove to themselves that they can function while afraid. how do you build a relationship with fear? And so understanding how to take on fear head-on, I think is a conditioning and understanding that comes with taking action and showing yourself, I know, I think I can do this.
“来吧，从明天开始你要勇敢。”我们通过帮助他们行动然后反思来教会他们。所以我们不是通过告诉他们“从明天开始要无所畏惧”或“去应对恐惧”来教导他们的。我们某种程度上让他们向自己证明，他们在害怕的同时也能发挥功能。你如何与恐惧建立一种关系？因此，理解如何迎难而上，我认为这是一种伴随着采取行动并向自己证明“我知道，我想我能做到”而产生的体悟和理解。
I was scared of snakes. I'm not scared of snakes. Now, it's important to distinguish on the one extreme when Aristotle wrote about courage, talked about cowardice at the one extreme and reckless at the other extreme. And courage was in the middle. So courage is about understanding the risks involved.
我以前害怕蛇。现在我不怕蛇了。需要区分的是，在极端情况下，亚里士多德在论述勇气时，将懦弱视为一个极端，而将鲁莽视为另一个极端。而勇气则居于中间。因此，勇气是关于理解其中涉及的风险。
What are the pros and cons of this action? You know, for the longest time, I was ashamed when I wasn't courageous. And I never understood this. And I've come to realize people aren't paralyzed by fear as much as they're paralyzed by the shame of having fear. And so I think it's important to understand for children to understand both one extreme recklessness, which I think for many of them is a factor to think about,
这种行为的利弊是什么？在很长一段时间里，当我表现得不够勇敢时，我会感到羞耻。我从来不理解这一点。后来我逐渐意识到，人们并不是被恐惧本身所瘫痪，而是被拥有恐惧的羞耻感所瘫痪。所以我认为，让孩子们理解两点非常重要：一个是极端鲁莽——我认为这对他们中的许多人来说是一个需要考虑的因素，
and the other one is not also to have shame. And how do we, I think this is an excellent question, that how do we get children to learn the act of courage? And it's about acting more than a lecture. In Aronio conversation, Ranja, you shared various methods of cultivating bravery as a scale. You talk about the idea of acting your way into knowing. We received a voicemail about acting your way into bravery from a listener named Aubrey.
另一个是不要感到羞耻。我们该如何——我认为这是一个极好的问题——如何让孩子们学会勇敢的行为？比起空洞的说教，行动更为重要。兰杰，在之前的谈话中，你分享了将勇敢作为一种刻度来培养的各种方法。你谈到了“以行动促认知”的理念。我们收到了一位名叫奥布里的听众发来的关于“以行动促勇敢”的语音留言。
When I heard the phrase acting your way into knowing, I immediately thought about the experience of transitioning and how for me I wasn't born knowing that I was a boy inside. you know, trapped in a girl's body. Instead, it was really a process, a very, very scary process of taking one step at a time, of, you know, taking hormones week after week, of getting surgery, of changing my name. And it was only by really acting that I was able to know. that this was right for me. It took a level of faith and courage in the face of fear of what people would think, of what the consequences for my life would be, and it's also been the best
当我听到“先去行动，自然就会明白”这句话时，我立刻想到了自己经历跨性别的过程，对我而言，我并不是生来就知道自己内心是个男孩，你知道的，被困在女孩的身体里。相反，这真的是一个过程，一个非常非常可怕的过程，需要一步一个脚印，你知道的，周复一周地使用荷尔蒙，接受手术，改名字。正是通过真正地付诸行动，我才明白这对我来说是正确的。面对人们会怎么想、生活会受到什么后果的恐惧，这需要一定程度的信念和勇气，这也是我做过的最棒的事。
thing that I've ever done. So Ranjay, Aubrey's message really underscores the idea that sometimes being brave can come before feeling brave. You know, I want to thank all for trusting us and sharing the story with us. And you're right. Sometimes, how do we think about acting before feeling? This story touches me because it highlights a quieter, sustained form of courage that you had talked about earlier. It's a profound example of choosing authenticity over safety. In some ways, you're waking up every day and you're trying to face the world that may be hostile, you may be willing to risk relationships, your social network, to be true to oneself. And so it really is, I think it's a powerful, powerful example of that courage doesn't always
所以，兰杰，奥布里的这段话真正强调了这样一个观点：有时，表现得勇敢可以先于感到勇敢。你知道的，我想感谢大家信任我们，并与我们分享这个故事。你说得对。有时候，我们该如何看待“先行动后感受”？这个故事触动了我，因为它突显了你之前谈到过的那种更安静、更持久的勇气。这是一个选择真实而非安全的深刻例子。在某种程度上，你每天醒来，都在试图面对一个可能有敌意的世界，你可能愿意冒着失去人际关系和社交网络的风险，来保持真实的自我。因此，我认为这是一个非常有力的例子，它证明了勇气并不总是
look like a warrior charging into battle or leading some kind of a movement. It sometimes requires patience, it's vulnerable. So it really expands our thinking about courage and also your point about, you know, your acting your way into knowing. So you're taking steps in that. It's a journey you're on. You're not doing it overnight. And so you're working your way into the fog,
看起来像一个冲锋陷阵或领导某种运动的勇士。它有时需要耐心，它是脆弱的。所以这确实拓展了我们对勇气的思考，也印证了你关于“先行动后明白”的观点。也就是说，你在其中采取了一步步的行动。这是一段你正在经历的旅程。你不是一夜之间完成的。所以你在迷雾中摸索前行，
not knowing what the consequences of this are going to be. You know they're going to be negative or maybe not, but you still are moving into the darkness because it's who you believe you are and what you are meant to be. We heard from a listener named Brad who shared a remarkable story. that made me wonder whether people can go not only from being fearful to brave, but also in the other direction. In 1988, Brad's father passed away.
不知道这样做的后果会是什么。你知道它们可能是消极的，也可能不会，但你依然走入黑暗，因为这就是你相信的自己，也是你注定要成为的人。我们听到一位名叫布拉德的听众分享了一个非凡的故事，这让我好奇，人们不仅能从恐惧走向勇敢，会不会也能朝相反的方向转变？1988年，布拉德的父亲去世了。
To work through his emotions, he decided to go on a bicycle trip through rural China. One evening, on a switchback through a mountain pass, he encountered a rough-looking crew of five men. They didn't let him pass. Their leader harassed him, pushed him, and even tried to punch him. So Brad took off, running. The men chased him. but he was able to find a small cave to hide it.
为了排解情绪，他决定去中国农村进行一次自行车旅行。一天傍晚，在翻越山隘的盘山公路上，他遇到了五个看起来很不友善的男人。他们不让他过去。他们的领头人骚扰他、推搡他，甚至试图用拳头打他。于是布拉德拔腿就跑。那些男人追了上去，但他幸运地找到了一个小山洞躲了起来。
It quickly got dark. It started to rain. It started to pour. I sat in a bowl in my tiny cave hole. And I sat as still as I could. I'd never been so cold. It was terrifying. And I was done adventuring.
天色迅速暗了下来。开始下雨了。下起了倾盆大雨。我坐在我那个狭小的洞穴里的一处凹陷中。我尽可能一动不动地坐着。我从未感到如此寒冷。太可怕了。我再也不想冒险了。
There had to be healthier ways to work through the death of a loved one. All I wanted now was a boring life for the rest of my days. I decided, if I lived to tell about this, I would return home and take over the family business. So the next morning, Ranjay, Brad was able to escape. He lived to tell the tale. But I'm wondering what you make of his story. Can we do scary things, decide that we've had enough, and then want to go back to a life that is much more cautious and safe? So, look, what we have experienced, there's two parts to this story. I think it's a great story, and I'm really grateful that Brad decided to share this with us.
肯定有更健康的办法来走出亲人离世的阴霾。我现在的全部愿望，就是余生过着平淡无奇的生活。我决定，如果我能活着讲述这段经历，我一定回家接管家族生意。所以第二天早上，兰杰，布拉德成功逃脱了。他活了下来，并讲述了这段经历。但我在想，你如何看待他的故事？我们是否会经历可怕的事情，在感到受够了之后，又想回到那种更加谨慎、安全的生活中去？所以，你看，我们所经历的，这个故事分为两部分。我认为这是一个很棒的故事，我非常感激布拉德决定与我们分享这段经历。
You know, what he has described here is what has been called conditioned fear. Fear learned through experience rather than logic. Conditioned fear is a learned nervous system response. So it's automatic, right? So the classic example of that is being bitten by a dog and then getting terrified of dogs. Or, you know, I watched the movie Jaws. Nothing happened to me, but I am so fearful.
你知道，他在这里描述的是所谓的条件性恐惧。通过经验而非逻辑学到的恐惧。条件性恐惧是一种习得的神经系统反应。所以它是自动的，对吧？最经典的例子就是被狗咬了一口，然后变得非常害怕狗。或者，你知道，我看了电影《大白鲨》。虽然我什么事都没发生，但自那以后我对下海变得无比恐惧。
of getting into the ocean after that. Right? And what starts to happen when it's activated in the nervous system, right? The amygdala is firing up before conscious thought. So the body reacts first. You know, we are an avoidance then reinforces the fear. And the way out of this is, you know, either you can let this fear amplify and paralyze your life
对吧？当它在神经系统中被激活时，会发生什么呢？杏仁核在有意识的思考之前就已经被激活了。所以身体会首先做出反应。你知道，我们的回避行为随后会加剧恐惧。摆脱这种状况的方法是，要么你任由这种恐惧放大并瘫痪你的生活，
and maybe you're happy doing that. Or the other way is to retrain the nervous system. Right. Gradual controlled exposure. An adventure trip doesn't have to mean going through rural China on a bicycle by yourself. Right? Maybe there are smaller steps along the way
也许你对此感到高兴。或者另一种方法是重新训练神经系统。对吧。渐进式的受控暴露。冒险之旅并不一定意味着独自一人骑自行车穿越中国农村。对吧？也许在此过程中可以采取更小的步骤，
where you can actually allow yourself the possibility of going on a guided tour, going to places that are safer. And what I've come to realize is that most of us are living our fears, not our dreams. And it's because we have, sometimes these conditioned responses that then become kind of a guiding principle that,
你可以真正允许自己尝试参加导游团，去更安全的地方。我逐渐意识到的是，我们大多数人都在靠恐惧生活，而不是靠梦想生活。这是因为我们有时会有这些条件反射，它们随后变成了一种指导原则，即，
oh, I'm conditioned, I'm not going to do it. I would urge Brad to, you know, explore if there's ways to voluntarily and gradually engage with it. I'm not, I totally respect where he's coming from, by the way, what he's describing is normal. It's an absolutely normal human response. but I also think that learning not the absence of fear is really the seed of courage so why allow this to paralyze one's life say you know what I get it
哦，我有条件反射，我不会这么做的。我敦促布拉德，你知道的，去探索是否有办法自愿且循序渐进地去面对它。顺便说一句，我完全尊重他的立场，他所描述的是正常的。这是一种绝对正常的应激反应。但我也认为，认识到恐惧并非不存在，才是真正的勇气之源，所以为什么要让恐惧瘫痪自己的人生呢？你可以说，好吧，我明白了，
it happened I have my nervous system is conditioned now to never do this again but maybe I can try something simple and small and as I do it I convince myself that I can do it It builds up my own confidence.
事情已经发生了，我的神经系统现在习惯了再也不要做这种事了，但也许我可以尝试一些简单的事情，随着我不断这样做，我让自己确信我是可以做到的。这建立了我自己的信心。
And honestly, it helps me overcome the trauma that I may, I probably went through. It must have been a, I can only imagine, but it sounds like a really traumatic experience. Brad's story also makes me reflect, Ranjay, that one thing that scary experiences do is they help us reflect on our lives, to see the value in more mundane and boring things in our lives. So as Brad sat shivering in the cave, he was fantasizing about how wonderful it would be to be bored. Is that one of the potential benefits that we get when we engage in dangerous activities, which is they remind us about all the times when our lives are not filled with danger and how wonderful that is? Well, no question about it. The contrast effect always helps, right?
老实说，这能帮助我克服我可能经历过的创伤。那一定是一次，我只能想象，但这听起来确实是一次极具创伤的经历。兰杰，布拉德的故事也让我反思，可怕经历带来的一点好处是，它们帮助我们反思生活，让我们看到生活中更多平凡和无趣事情的价值。正如布拉德蜷缩在山洞里瑟瑟发抖时，他一直在幻想无聊的生活会有多美好。当我们从事危险活动时，这是我们获得的潜在好处之一吗？也就是说，它们提醒我们想起生活中没有危险的所有时光，以及那是多么美好？嗯，毫无疑问。对比效应总是很有帮助，对吧？
What courage does or these risky or crucible moments do is they shift our sense of time. Instead of just being trapped by the present threat and what's happening here, we start to also imagine ourselves in longer arcs. Like, what do I want my life to add up to? So I think courageous moments and courageous actions can be powerful kind of moments of self-reflection. So that's up to us of how we then translate these moments and allow them to be part of our future lives.
勇气或这些充满风险的严峻时刻所做的事情，是它们改变了我们的时间感。我们不再仅仅被当前的威胁和眼前发生的事情所困扰，而是开始想象更长远的未来。比如，我希望我的人生累积成什么样？所以我认为，勇敢的时刻和勇敢的行动可以成为深刻的自我反思的时刻。所以这取决于我们如何转化这些时刻，并让它们成为我们未来生活的一部分。
When we come back, is courage always a good thing? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Throughout human history, storytellers have extolled the virtues of courage. From the biblical tale of David and Goliath to the latest superhero movies, we love characters who are brave. But bravery isn't always easy. It can be messy, dangerous.
休息之后，勇气总是件好事吗？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。贯穿人类历史，说书人们一直在颂扬勇气的崇高品质。从圣经中大卫与歌利亚的故事，到最新的超级英雄电影，我们都热爱勇敢的角色。但勇敢并非总是那么容易。它可能会变得一团糟，充满危险。
Leaders like Mahatma Gandhi and Martin Luther King Jr. went to prison and eventually lost their lives to their causes. An employee who confronts an unethical boss may lose her job. A student who turns in a cheating classmate could get called a snitch. Ranjay Guladi is the author of How to Be Bold, the surprising science of everyday courage. Runji, let's look at some of the challenges involved with courage. Some listeners pointed out that their ability to be brave
像圣雄甘地和马丁·路德·金这样的领袖为了他们的事业曾入狱，并最终献出了生命。一个敢于对抗不道德老板的员工可能会失去工作。一个举报作弊同学的学生可能会被骂作告密者。兰杰·古拉蒂是《如何果断：日常勇气的惊人科学》一书的作者。兰杰，让我们来看看与勇气相关的一些挑战。一些听众指出，他们表现出勇敢的能力
depends not only on what the situation is, but on who is involved. Here's Kay. I've realized I've had no problem or hesitation, inserting myself into any arena if I'm seeing someone getting bullied, if I'm seeing someone throw a piece of trash, or if there's a natural design. I don't seem to hesitate to react or respond and what I feel like is courage and standing up for what I morally believe is right. What I found interesting is though I, if it involves me, I have a much more difficult time standing up for myself.
不仅取决于具体情况，还取决于涉及的人是谁。听听凯怎么说。我意识到，如果我看到有人被欺凌、看到有人乱扔垃圾，或者出现某种自然灾害，我介入任何场合并挺身而出时，都没有任何问题或犹豫。对于捍卫我在道德上认为是正确的事情，我似乎毫不犹豫地做出反应，这就是我所认为的勇气。我发现有趣的是，如果事情牵涉到我自己，我却很难为自己挺身而出。
I struggle, but if it's in the moment or for someone else, I don't seem to hesitate. I'm curious about that psychology around that. So, Ranj, I feel like many people can relate to this. Our likelihood to show courage can vary based on who is the aggressor and who is the victim. What do you make of this? First of all, that's absolutely true. Courage is deeply, deeply contextual, you know, and social psychology has shown us that. Like, we're more likely to take action if we identify with a victim, you know, like in the story of Suzanne, we feel empathy.
我很挣扎，但如果是当下的情况或者是为了别人，我似乎就不会犹豫。我对其中的心理机制很好奇。所以，兰杰，我觉得很多人都能对此感同身受。我们表现出勇气的可能性会根据施暴者和受害者的不同而变化。你对此怎么看？首先，这绝对是真的。勇气有着极深的情境性，你知道的，社会心理学已经向我们证明了这一点。比如，如果我们对受害者感同身受，我们就更有可能采取行动，就像苏珊的故事一样，我们感受到了同理心。
Or if we feel safe in our group, safety in numbers. Conversely, if the aggressor is some kind of a powerful authority figure, the perceived cost skyrocket. So we have to stop looking at courage as some kind of individual trait. And recognize it is also a response to the power dynamics we are within. We also know that people are more likely to act when they feel personally responsible. The bystander effect where there are many people diffuses responsibility. be. So our willingness to act is highly context dependent. Now, I think it's also in her case, for whatever reason, she's created in her mind a block where she's willing to stand up for
或者，如果我们感到在我们的群体中是安全的，即人多安全。相反，如果施暴者是某种强大的权威人物，那么感知到的成本就会急剧飙升。因此，我们必须停止将勇气视为某种单一的个人特质。并认识到它也是对我们所处权力动态的一种反应。我们也知道，当人们感到自己负有个人责任时，更有可能采取行动。旁观者效应则是人多反而分散了责任。因此，我们采取行动的意愿高度取决于情境。现在，我认为在她的情况下，无论出于什么原因，她在心中设置了一种阻碍，使她愿意为
others and causes that go beyond herself. But somehow she has decided that she herself is not somebody that she wants to take bold steps for. Whether she feels them as heightened risk, not worth taking, or she experiences that something that doesn't align with herself belief. Hard for me to say. But I think she'd be so well served if she did allow herself to experience courage in her own life. You know, I'm thinking in some ways of an analogy here, Ranjay. Many parents, I think, experienced this. They might be, you know, meek and cautious people most of the time. But if their kids were in danger, you know, lion dad and lioness mom, you know, come out. And so there are some situations that really bring out the protector in us, that bring out the defender in us.
他人以及超越自身的信念挺身而出。但不知何故，她决定了她自己并不是那个她愿意采取大胆步骤去保护的人。无论是她觉得风险太高、不值得冒，还是她认为这与自己的信念不符。这很难说。但我认为，如果她能允许自己在自己的生活中体验勇气，她将受益匪浅。你知道，兰杰，我在这里想到了一种类比。许多父母，我想他们都经历过这种情况。他们平时可能都是温和谨慎的人。但如果他们的孩子们处于危险之中，你知道的，雄狮般的父亲和母狮般的母亲就会挺身而出。因此，有些情况确实能激发出我们心中的保护欲，激发出我们心中的捍卫者。
And we don't do this for everyone. And sometimes we don't do this for ourselves. Yes, absolutely. And you're absolutely right. So that's a great illustration of context dependence of courage that in certain conditions we are willing to. Now, the parent-child, I think, is almost genetically hardwired in us, as we know, helping our own genetic pool survive. but people stand up for causes which I find is
我们不会对所有人这样做。有时我们也不会为自己这样做。是的，绝对如此。你完全说得对。这是一个关于勇气情境依赖性的绝佳例证：在某些条件下，我们愿意这样做。现在，父母与孩子的关系，正如我们所知，几乎是我们基因中硬编码的一部分，它有助于我们自身的基因库得以延续，
that go beyond them I describe in my book the Freedom Summer where these young undergraduate mostly white kids went down to Mississippi for a voter registration drive and most of them stayed
但人们也会为了超越自身的崇高事业挺身而出，我在书中描述了“自由之夏”运动，当时这些年轻的大学生（主要是白人年轻人）前往密西西比州参加选民登记运动，其中大多数人留了下来，
even after a few were lynched in the first few days and so what is it that leads people to risk life and limb for something they believe in. I think that to me is another piece to think about where people do extraordinary things in pursuit of something that aligns with their own belief
甚至在头几天有几个人被残酷虐杀之后依然如此。那么，究竟是什么促使人们为了他们信仰的事物甘冒生命危险呢？我认为，对我来说，这是另一个值得思考的维度，人们为了追求符合自身信念的事物，会做出非凡的举动，
and their own judgment of themselves and aligns with their own values. A listener named Thomas called in from China. He says that years ago, in his career, he stood up to his boss over what he felt were unethical business practices. Surprisingly, the boss recognized the error and publicly apologized. But looking back now, Thomas realizes his courage might not have all been about courage, some of it might have been the unthinking rashness of youth.
以及符合他们对自己的判断，并且符合他们自己的价值观。一位名叫托马斯的听众从中国打来电话。他说，多年前在他的职业生涯中，他曾因他认为不道德的商业行为而顶撞过老板。令他惊讶的是，老板承认了错误并公开道歉。但现在回过头来看，托马斯意识到他当时的勇气可能并不全是因为勇敢，其中一部分可能只是年轻人未经思考的鲁莽。
The courage that I had at that time is really very rare in my life, in fact, because as I grew older, as I became more and more socially experienced, I just to find that I have gradually lost that kind of courage. Because at that time, I didn't know what the consequences were. I didn't know what I was doing. In fact, I just wanted to play a hero, if you will. So I want to ask, is ignorance? Actually, a vector that leads to courage.
我当时拥有的勇气在我的生活中其实非常罕见，事实上，因为随着我年龄的增长，随着我社会经验越来越丰富，我发现自己逐渐失去了那种勇气。因为当时我不知道后果是什么。我不知道自己在做什么。事实上，如果你愿意的话，我只是想扮演一个英雄。所以我想问，无知，
Thank you. Ranj, I'm wondering what you make of Thomas' question. Can ignorance be a source of courage? So Thomas asks a great question. And the honest answer is yes, sometimes, but with the important caveat to think about. Ignorance can be a spark that triggers someone to take, not knowing the full danger,
实际上是通往勇气的催化剂吗？
can help you take the first step, but to sustain courage, even in that particular story or over a car course of your life requires building awareness of courage. My gentle suggestion to Thomas is to learn to build a relationship with fear. To learn to lean into that discomfort that comes with being uncomfortable, that comes with fear. And to say, like, you know, what is it that I really believe in? what is important to me
谢谢。兰杰，我想知道你如何看待托马斯的问题。无知能成为勇气的源泉吗？因此，托马斯提出了一个很好的问题。诚实的回答是：有时可以，但需要加上一个重要的前提来思考。无知可以成为触发某人采取行动的火花，不知道全部的危险，
how can I do things whether it's a sport or it's an outdoor hobby or it's travel or something that takes me out of my quote-unquote cocoon it's like recognizing that something else is more important than just fear and giving in to our fears
可以帮助你迈出第一步，但要保持勇气，即使在那个特定的故事中或在你的一生中，也需要建立对勇气的觉察。我对托马斯的温和建议是，学会与恐惧建立关系。学会去倾斜并适应这种伴随着不适感、伴随着恐惧而来的不适。并且去思考，比如，“我真正信仰的是什么？什么对我来说是重要的？”
we received an interesting message from a listener named Stephen about the line between bravery and recklessness the same line you were talking about a moment to go. A couple of years ago, Stephen narrowly escaped a shark attack. He actually had to hit the shark on its snout to make it go away. Now, that scary incident didn't deter him sometime later from getting back into the ocean. I let him pick up the story. So I get in the water. I'm swimming, and there's two sets of breakers, so I'm swimming about 100 yards out and I'm about a half an hour
我该如何去做事，无论是通过运动、户外爱好、旅行，还是其他任何能让我走出所谓的“作茧自缚”的事情？这就像是认识到还有比单纯的恐惧和向恐惧妥协更重要的事情。
into the swim. And as my right arm enters the water, I guess it must look just like, a fish going into the water because a shark comes up from underneath me grasped my right arm pulls me under shakes the heck out of me and then lets me go i guess he figures i'm not a fish and uh so i'm coming up i'm like oh this is going to be bad as i lift my arm out of the water to look at it and blood's going everywhere so i'm trying to swim in uh on my side with my left arm like side stroke and keep my right arm out of the water so the sharks don't come back and it's rough and it's oh gosh so there's one person on the beach and I'm yelling for her as I'm swimming in and luckily she stopped and she calls 911 and they um they take me off I pass out I guess and uh I wake up the next day and
我们收到了一位名叫斯蒂芬的听众发来的一条有趣的留言，内容是关于勇敢与鲁莽之间的界限，也就是你刚才谈到的那条界限。几年前，斯蒂芬险些遭遇鲨鱼袭击。他实际上不得不击打鲨鱼的鼻子才把它赶跑。现在，那次可怕的事件并没有阻止他在一段时间后重新回到海里。我让他来讲讲这个故事。所以我下水了。我在游泳，那里有两道碎浪，所以我游到了大约100码远的地方，我已经游了大约半个小时。
surgeons did a great job I'm fixing my they fixed my arm pretty much I didn't lose my arm and I did a lot of rehab myself and I'm still rehabbing but I'm doing great I'm doing great I'm in the water and I'm swim and I'll swim on rough days. But, uh, so that, that's my question. You know, is this, um, cross the line from facing your fears into stupidity? Or, um, anyways, thank you for the show. I love the show. Wondering what you think, Ranjay, um, was Stephen being brave or was Stephen being reckless?
当我的右臂入水时，我想它一定看起来就像一条游入水中的鱼，因为一条鲨鱼从我身下冲上来，抓住了我的右臂，把我拉到水下，疯狂地摇晃我，然后把我放开。我想它大概觉得我不是一条鱼，然后我浮了上来，我想“这下糟了”，当我把手臂从水中抬起来看它时，血流得到处都是。所以我试着侧身用左臂划水游回岸边，采用侧泳姿势，并把右臂抬出水面，这样鲨鱼就不会回来了。海浪很大，哦天哪，海滩上只有一个人，我一边往岸边游一边向她大喊。幸运的是她停了下来并拨打了911，他们把我带走了，我想我昏迷了过去。第二天我醒来时，
There's a defined line there. And what I would say the line is, the dividing line between those two is acknowledgement. bravery acknowledges the risk and chooses to act for a higher purpose or other beliefs or other factors that propel you to consciously take action right recklessness on the other hand
外科医生做得非常出色，他们修复了我的胳膊，我的胳膊基本上保住了，没有截肢。我自己做了很多康复训练，现在仍在康复中，但我恢复得很好，我恢复得很好。我在水里游泳，在风浪大的日子里也会游。但是，这就是我的问题。你知道，这算不算是越过了正视恐惧、走向愚蠢的界限？或者，无论如何，感谢你们的节目。我很喜欢这个节目。兰杰，你想一想，斯蒂芬当时是在表现勇敢，还是在表现鲁莽？
ignores or minimizes the risk often for the thrill or out of negligence now he's going back into the water if there are big signs saying there are sharks out right now today is not a good day to be out there and he still chooses to go out, I would say that's reckless, right? But if he's back out in an ocean where there have been no sightings of sharks,
那里有一条明确的界限。我要说的是，这两者之间的分界线是：认可。勇敢承认风险的存在，并选择为了更高的目标、其他信念或其他促使你清醒地采取行动的因素而行动。而鲁莽则是，
it's a completely clear, that shows brave. And he has decided that he will not let that previous experience completely control his life. Now, he happens to have bad luck and there happens to be a shark that day. That's bad luck. but I think recklessness comes in where you know what, I'm just going to go out anyway, I don't care.
为了寻求刺激或出于疏忽，往往会忽视或淡化风险。现在，如果他再次下水时，有大大的标志标明现在有鲨鱼出没，今天不是下水的好日子，而他依然选择下水，我会说那是鲁莽，对吧？但如果他重新回到一片没有鲨鱼出没记录的海域，
Yeah. Now it's also the case, of course, that there are many situations where it's not clear what the risks are, right? So in other words, there's no sign that is posted. If you're dealing with, let's say, confronting an authoritarian regime, maybe you don't have signs saying, you know, your risk today is 25%.
那完全是一片晴朗的海域，这就表现出了勇敢。而且他已经决定，他不会让那次先前的经历完全控制他的生活。现在，他碰巧运气不好，那天刚好碰上了一条鲨鱼。那是运气不好。但我认为鲁莽体现在：你知道吗，我不管三七二十一就是要去，我不在乎。
Your risk today is 65%. Is it always possible to know? what the risk is before venturing in, Ranjee? That's a great question. And, you know, in my book, actually, I make a distinction between risk and uncertainty. You know, risk is where you know the probability of outcomes and you can put some numbers to it and the shark example is one of them, signs saying shark sightings have happened. There are sharks in the area.
是的。当然，这也是事实，在许多情况下，风险并不明确，对吧？换句话说，没有设立任何告示牌。如果你面对的是，比如说，对抗一个威权政权，也许你并没有看到写着“你今天的风险是25%”的告示牌。
Uncertainty is where we don't know, right? where maybe you go into a remote place or a country where they don't track shark movements and in these unknown uncertainty comes in and uncertainty actually is what really paralyzes the brain that activates the fear impulse like nothing else and then the question is how do you choose to act or not act there was a book called the benefits of fear which said that fear is a surveillance Bible impulse don't ignore it, which I do agree with also.
“你今天的风险是65%”。在冒险之前，总是能够知道风险是什么吗，兰杰？这是一个很好的问题。而且，你知道的，在我的书中，我实际上区分了风险和不确定性。你知道，风险是指你了解结果的概率，并且可以为之赋予一些数字，鲨鱼的例子就是其中之一，有标志表明曾发生过鲨鱼目击事件。该地区有鲨鱼。
But I also think that we can't let it completely paralyze us because there's so much uncertainty in the world today. If you're going to succumb to all forms of uncertainty, you will never do anything. So it's learning how to find that line between bravery and recklessness. If you remember, one extreme was cowardice, other extreme was reckless, in the middle sits bravery. Ranjay is a behavioral scientist at the Harvard Business School.
不确定性则是我们所不知道的，对吧？比如你去了偏远的地方或一个不追踪鲨鱼动向的国家，未知的不确定性就在这里介入了。而真正瘫痪大脑、以前所未有的方式激活恐惧冲动的恰恰是不确定性。那么问题来了，你如何选择行动还是不行动？有一本书叫做《恐惧的好处》，其中说恐惧是一种警示性的冲动，不要忽视它，我也赞同这一点。
He is the author of How to Be Bold, the surprising science of everyday courage. We also heard today from political scientist Erica Chenoweth also at Harvard. Erica is the author of Civil Resistance, What Everyone Needs to Know, and with Maria Stefan, why civil resistance works,
但我也认为，我们不能让它完全瘫痪我们，因为当今世界上存在着太多的不确定性。如果你要屈服于所有形式的不确定性，你将永远一事无成。因此，关键在于学习如何找到勇敢与鲁莽之间的那条界限。如果你还记得的话，一个极端是怯懦，另一个极端是鲁莽，而勇敢则居于中间。兰杰是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。
the strategic logic of nonviolent conflict. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
他是《如何果断：日常勇气的惊人科学》一书的作者。我们今天还听取了同样来自哈佛的政治学家埃里卡·陈韦思的意见。埃里卡是《公民抵抗：每个人都需要知道的事》的作者，她与玛丽亚·斯特凡合著了《为什么公民抵抗有效：非暴力冲突的战略逻辑》。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Thank you to Loom by Atlassian for sponsoring the Hidden Brain Perceptions Tour. While on tour, audience members shared the best piece of advice they've ever received. At our tour stop in Baltimore, a listener named Sanjeev, told us about a piece of career advice he received from a friend. Sanjeev says he had always struggled with networking until his friend told him something that changed his whole perspective.
感谢 Atlassian 旗下的 Loom 赞助《隐藏的大脑·知觉巡回演出》。在巡回演出期间，观众们分享了他们收到的最好的建议。在我们的巴尔的摩巡演站，一位名叫桑吉夫的听众向我们讲述了他从朋友那里得到的职业建议。桑吉夫说他以前一直在社交网络方面苦苦挣扎，直到他的朋友对他说了一番话，改变了他的整个看法。
I heard how important networking was, but I didn't know how to do it. I didn't think I was a good networker. So I went to one of my friends who I considered to be the best networker I've ever met. I'm like, how do you do it, Ed? How do you do networking? Because I can't do it. I'm intimidated by it. And he said, Sanjeev, when I meet with people, I don't think about what they can do for me,
我听说过社交网络有多么重要，但我不知道该怎么做。我不认为自己是个擅长社交的人。所以我去找了我的一位朋友，我认为他是我见过的最擅长社交的人。我说：“埃德，你是怎么做到的？你是如何进行社交的？因为我做不到。我对它感到很畏缩。”他说：“桑吉夫，当我与人们见面时，我不会去想他们能为我做什么，
but what I can do for them. It was such a simple but profound message that day. It reoriented my thinking. And from that point on, I've never been afraid to just go and meet people. Thank you. Wonderful. Thank you so much.
而是去想我能为他们做些什么。”那是一个如此简单却又深奥的信息。它重新调整了我的思维。从那时起，我再也不害怕去结识新朋友了。谢谢。太棒了。非常感谢。
Thanks to Sanjeev for sharing that piece of advice. And thanks again to Lume for sponsoring the perceptions tour. LUMM is AI-first-powered video communication that moves teams forward, whether you're sharing feedback, obtaining approvals, or setting context. Reduce unnecessary meetings and make the ones that matter more effective. Unstuck your teams today at loom.com. That's L-O-O-O-M.com.
感谢桑吉夫分享这个建议。再次感谢 Lume 赞助知觉巡回演出。LUMM 是一款人工智能驱动的视频沟通工具，无论您是分享反馈、获取批准还是设定背景，它都能推动团队向前发展。减少不必要的会议，让重要的会议更具成效。今天就访问 loom.com，帮你的团队摆脱困境。网址是 L-O-O-O-M.com。
It's a team changer. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它能改变整个团队。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。